Uh, there is a rule which is that there was
supposed to be extra consideration given to
military veterans in immigration cases, meaning
that if you have a military veteran, uh, who
does not have legal status or maybe was here
on a visa that has expired and they have not
been able to get citizenship as a result of
being in the military yet that special consideration
is given to them when you process them through
the immigration, uh, sort of court system
and adjudication system.
And unfortunately the Donald Trump administration
is not following that rule.
More and more non citizens are being deported.
Who are veterans of the American military?
How many we don't actually know because record
keeping has been so atrocious.
The government accountability office found
that 250 veterans are subject to removal.
92 have been deported.
We've deported nearly a hundred military veterans.
The issue here is not legality issue here
is that officials are going against their
own guidelines about how this is supposed
to be handled.
There are two memos since 2004, uh, addressing
exactly this issue.
There's a memo from 2015 which says that any
time you are looking at deporting a military
veteran, it must be set for a higher review.
If you are going to deport a military veteran,
you need a special document explaining why
is it that you are deporting this military
veteran.
This is not being done.
Okay, and there's this meme that we've dealt
with many times before, which is that the
right supports the troops and the left doesn't.
And of course this could not be further from
the truth.
I've said before, yeah, I'm on the left and
I support the troops.
I don't want to send them to military conflicts
as political pawns where they may be injured
or killed or traumatized for life.
That's how I support the troops by really
making military action the absolute last resort
and using it so sparingly.
Only when we really are a, an immediate danger,
not fighting political wars the way Republicans
have been doing for decades at this point
in time.
Healthcare, I support the troops by making
sure that, or wanting at least I can't make
sure personally and the system is not working
well, but demanding and asking for veterans
to really get good medical care.
And it's got to happen with immigration as,
and it is not happening here.
The Republicans love veterans as props, props
on stages, props on aircraft carriers when
they declare mission accomplished, dead veterans
that they can honor and use for political
gain.
But when it comes to just treating them like
real people, recognizing their sacrifice,
when we consider their immigration status,
when we consider the health care that we provide
to them, when we consider job opportunities
that we are furnishing, that is where all
of a sudden the right does not care.
I wish the support the troops brigade on the
right simply supported them for real.
And uh, it's disgusting that this is going
on.
And this is an example of why we can't allow
Trump to use Twitter to set the narrative
and to distract from really serious things
that are going on.